[Applause]  the winner of The Voice is  boiler alert The Voice has crowned its  newest champion after Tuesday night's  incredible Season 22 finale if you  haven't caught up with the latest  episode of the show you might want to  look away now  congratulations  [Applause]  that's right country star Bryce  Leatherwood sang his way to Victory  earning a record-extending ninth win for  his coach Blake Shelton  price  [Music]  you already made it man  you literally already made it I know  my genre and I know the country music  fans out there  you got a career ahead of you dude  congratulations already  Bryce went over both the coaches and  viewers at home throughout the season  with his Countryside performances  including a duet of Whitney Houston's  Saving All My Love For You with fellow  finalists Morgan miles  foreign  although Season 22 was his last with  wife Gwen Stefani The Voice will return  for Blake's 23rd and final season in  2023